you know the Trump strategy right now is  Biden is an addled you know weak  doddering old man he's really lowering  the bar for Biden in these debates you  know it's possible that Biden can  actually seal this simply by clearing  the very low bar that Trump has set for  him but then the real work begins  yes because we're still going to have  like tens of millions of Americans who  are completely at a loss as to what the  way forward looks like you know there's  a passionate desire to get past this  Donald Trump era and I understand it but  if that's all that happens that's not  enough and my sense is that that's not  what Biden wants